[Music]
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
folks welcome back to game spots
coverage of summer game fest 2022. you
are here with us sometime in the morning
maybe the afternoon wherever you are
because we're about to lead into the
epic game stores
store showcase
i think that's what it is summer
showcase summer showcase i'm curtin
devina and joining me today is devante
chisholm
look at this setup we didn't have these
yesterday but we have them today and
they just look absolutely fantastic
fantastic fantastic anyways folks we're
not here to talk about the setup we're
here to talk about games we're here to
talk about epic games store showcase of
their store we don't exactly know what
it is um
devonte well we know what the store is
but we don't know what they're going to
do
um
and you're a big epic game store user
i'm a big epic game store uh user but
how many games have you bought it let's
say that lightly because um
you know i'm kind of like that office
meme where the guy's like shaking uh
i'm blanking on steve carrell's
character's name the last person to ask
about i am a horrible office fan when
he's like shaking his hand thanking him
because i i don't buy things from the
epic game store i think a lot of you
might be able to
like kind of connect with me on this
where we're just hitting redeem on those
free games every week and that is all my
library is on epic game store but
they're great games
look i also have a confession
i don't use it i haven't used it yet
okay um but with context you know i i
play games in a very specific way
on very specific devices my pc setup
isn't the greatest
um so i haven't had a chance
i know but here hopefully i mean we're
here to watch this every we can't be
experts in everything yeah i'm doing my
best but you know before we're going
into this like we really don't know what
we're going to see because this is
specifically for the store
um and i just was doing a little
research prior to see it's like well
what i know epic games you know kind of
like this this push for exclusivity on
pc specifically um since steam was the
own all sort of uh distributor for games
and i was actually kind of surprised to
see like if you're a pc gamer
specifically um if you want to play the
evil dead game you got to play it on
epic game store yep fortnite you can
play that anywhere on the toilet on your
iphone but if you want to play on pc
epic game store
alan awake one and two and nail in wake
or no well soon to call mail in wake too
not yet and wake one and alan wake
remaster
epic game story rocket league epic games
rocket league epic game store
so i mean who knows maybe that's what
the showcase is going to be
maybe we're going to get a glimmer into
finding out some upcoming games that are
only going to be exclusive uh to epic
game store or maybe we'll just be like
maybe epic games would be like look at
all the sweet deals we have you know the
steam summer sale
get a load of the epic game store sale
it's yeah it's going right now i think
it's called like the mega epic game
store sale or something like that it has
like a week left but
i don't know i i think we we did get a
commercial for that yesterday during um
the summer game fest live event
i i feel like maybe we'll get another
one of those and then they might go into
some of like the exclusives and and
things like that whatever's coming out
in the future i think we see some saints
row because the demo um for the
character creator is only on epic game
store if you're okay from pc so we might
see a little saints row which you were
excited about which i am i am very
excited about um saints row the demo and
the full game
so it would be it would be cool to see a
little more of that i think we've seen a
decent amount but
sure show me more are you gonna make
your
a
a pitch perfect replication of devante
are you gonna like
nope i am going to go straight to making
you
really 100 you know it's it's it's gonna
it's gonna be fantastic i think i'll
make everybody in the gs crew and and
post those those pictures just run me
right into traffic
[Laughter]
sure i mean when the game finally comes
out you can uh
we can we can figure out exactly what
type of criminal you are and we'll go
from there do you have to be a criminal
um yes um yeah
the whole point of saying
you're trying to bring your gang what do
you think in the criminal underworld so
i don't think you can go about the game
being very
nice unless you just don't go to a
mission unless you don't just unless you
don't download the game at all unless
you just run me out in the traffic what
kind of what kind of what kind of
criminal you think i'd be
um
i think i think you're stealing clothes
clothes yeah i think you're i think
you're stealing sneakers i was gonna say
i was gonna say like hamburger
sneakers are your main thing but when
you're hungry yeah you steal so i'm
gonna like
sainsbury's gonna come out you're gonna
make me mm-hmm and you're gonna run me
a pass traffic past traffic and i'm
gonna go right for jeff keely right to
jeff kelly i want his sneakers whatever
hamburgers and sneakers he has in his
bag at that moment or on his personal
shoes and from his pockets hamburgers
and shoes
i mean we also like
to get on track we also uh there's other
few exclusives like games that um have
only been announced recently like ghost
uh buster's
spirits unleashed
um astro magical
multiplayer game uh which is gonna be
actually that's i actually don't know
what the console situation of that is
off the top my head i apologize
uh that i'm not that database yeah off
off the cuff um but that is a game i
would be really eager to play i'm a
phasmaphobia fan
and
it seems cool yeah oh yeah it seems like
a lot of people have a great time with
that game you wouldn't believe it good
but devonte
has a big he loves to get scared the
biggest
um i just you know i haven't been able
to download that game for whatever
reason my pc just can't handle it it's a
mystery to me but i'll get around to it
anyways so we're gonna play that
together sometime um whether you like it
or not your computer i'm gonna send you
a computer with it on there if it's not
it's a problem
ghostbusters spirits unleashed is like
you know seems like a maybe not as
spooky maybe not as scary as my phobia
but i love that type of uh of of game uh
and or at least where you have to use
like it's almost like a puzzle enough
itself like kind of a use detective yes
yes use specific devices like
communicate with each other how you can
like
lure this ghost out but in that case you
can play in a ghostbusters experience
unless you like you can play as the
ghost at the entire time which is not
the case in phasmophobia it's just for
the uh cpu yeah um but if that's the
case
that's one of those games that i would
actually be interested in be like you
know what
epic game store maybe got me maybe i'll
download it
pop it on there maybe they'll shadow
drop like a demo today or something i
don't know we'll find out because it's
about to happen right now for those of
you who are just tuning in you're about
to see the epic game store summer
showcase here through gamespot see you
after
hello and welcome to the epic game store
summer showcase our home for new
announcements updates and an extended
look at some of our favorite upcoming pc
games
we have a lot of great games to see
today so let's get started
the forge's fire has a long gone cold
[Music]
under the mountain of durian's folk
[Music]
a shadow took our treasured halls
now
it calls us back
casa doom
[Music]
[Applause]
speak friend
and enter
[Music]
from deep below the misty mountain rises
a new adventure in an ancient place
lord of the rings return to morya is an
epic game store pc exclusive dropping in
2023
wish list today to stay up to date on
this exciting return to the ancient
dwarven kingdom of
kazadoom
hello there this is jordan from mophonic
and today i'm excited to give you a
quick look at the ectoplast one of our
ghost types and ghostbusters spirits
unleashed along with the main stat and
visual differences of ghost types within
each type there will be several variants
which further mix up gameplay with
unique abilities picking the variant
that suits your gameplay is crucial to
effectively haunting any building winky
slams down a massive puddle of sludge to
slow and coat anyone caught in its
vicinity if precision and distance is
your preference poki's ecto torpedo has
some serious range and knockback power
brainy conjures and throws a massive
glob which can be held for longer
periods producing more powerful results
slimer's noxious belch hurls a massive
amount of slime forward coating the
victims in a powerful stream last but
not least there's the ectoplas ultimate
ability slime nato flailing massive
amounts of slime out around you is a
great way to get yourself out of
numerous sticky situations
i hope you enjoyed this quick look at
the ectoplast ghost type keep an eye out
for more to be revealed over the coming
months as we approach our q4 launch
the epic mega sale is going on right now
you can find huge discounts on pc games
across the epic game store
and claim a free game during each week
of the sale
this week's free game is man eater
head over to the store right now to
claim it for yourself and check out some
of the great deals
[Music]
we interrupt this broadcast to bring you
a special announcement the pc building
simulator 2 open veda is now live
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do a gunslinging space frog and a
sword-wheeling robot have in common
saving the universe that's what
up next we're taking a look at shoulders
of giants
[Music]
[Music]
shoulders of giants is an epic game
store pc exclusive releasing in 2022. if
you're interested in this intergalactic
tale of good versus evil add it to your
wish list today
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey everyone in chia you can take
control of any object or animal you can
find in the open world it's called snow
jumping and it's up to you to use it at
your advantage for traversal and
exploration but also during enemy
encounters here's some new gameplay
footage from chia coming early 2023
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know we had a lot of great games
launched on the store recently
let's take a look back at some
highlights and get updates on a few
player favorites along the way
this is in case you missed it
don't quit
that beat they just won't let go
ain't faking
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
let's go back
[Music]
hey there's one over here
the sun is high in the sky
[Music]
green fields keep rolling
[Music]
[Music]
an epic game store pc exclusive goat
simulator 3 has our favorite barnyard
protagonists looking their way through a
whole new world of physics inspired
mayhem
add it to your wish list today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
corporation is snatching up contestants
for a speed wrangling event do you have
what it takes to raise the stakes are
you ready
sucked up too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fans of competitive fortnite rejoice it
is my great pleasure to announce that
this november in raleigh north carolina
will be inviting 100 players to go head
to head for their cut of a one million
dollar prize pool
we will see who can rise above the rest
and win the first official in person
fncs event for all the details check out
at fn competitive on twitter
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
we've been working hard since open beta
and now is the best time to play rogue
company we've added nine rogues seven
maps nine weapons and twelve gamers we'd
like to thank the entire community for
your continued support roe company would
not be here without you today now we're
officially launching road company
leading up to launch we've worked hard
on quality of life improvements and
making rogues feel even more unique and
we're not stopping there we're launching
with a brand new rogue juke quick witted
and quick on her feet juke outplays her
opponents with her rocket dash and
turrets it all starts with four weeks of
exhilarating events available for all
players throughout the event expect
increased rogue mastery a fully unlocked
arsenal of weapons and increased
contract rewards to celebrate all rogues
will be unlocked for the first week of
launch we're not done yet at launch
we're releasing a new battle pass called
wasteland wilds packed with new skins
emotes and more to celebrate the epic
games showcase we have a free bundle in
the shop today now is the best time to
go rogue
[Music]
i could do this all day
anyone want to join me
i'm just getting warmed up
[Music]
are you kidding me
ah come on
you must be allergic to gods
thanks for tuning in to the epic game
store summer showcase
we hope you enjoyed the fresh look at
some of our favorite games coming to the
store
don't forget to follow our social
channels for more updates and be sure to
wishlist your favorite titles from
today's show to stay up to date on news
and discounts
and now please enjoy this special look
at the saints row boss factory take care
everyone
[Music]
it's our time now
let's get this started
[Music]
[Music]
showtime
[Applause]
[Music]
that my friend is what boss building is
all about
crap
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to gamespot's coverage of
summer game fest we just finished up
watching epic game stores game store
showcase i'm curt divina joining me
today is davonte chisholm hello there he
is
and that was a that was kind of a breezy
breezy look at some exclusives for the
epic game sport store before we uh we
went into it i was kind of talking about
uh
you know i'm not a big epic game store
user
and i know they're kind of making a big
push for their they're kind of like one
of the only things in the space right
now that are kind of pushing for like
exclusivity on their publishing on their
platform devonta has used it a bit what
do you think of that show what have you
thought about it um i it was kind of
what i expected you know we we got a
little look at a couple of their
exclusives and not too much of like deep
dives or anything i was kind of hoping
for a little bit more on at least
something like for ghostbusters that was
pretty quick like that was a very fast
look at like a ghost type and it was in
and out it even felt like our narrator
was like kind of speaking fast um to get
through it he was doing his best job
yeah
you did a great job i'm just saying i i
thought it would be just a tiny bit more
i think uh
i think if anything has served as just a
reminder yeah it was like it felt kind
of like them just making sure they were
in the public eye summer game fast big
jeff keeley show there's no e3
they have at least you know it's like
putting the billboard up making sure
they have like some
in the eyes just to remind you that epic
game store exists that's really just
like if if my whole takeaway
it was safe nothing really like there
was no big announcement it's not that
there's like they have to not that was
expected yeah but they did throw in a
lot of like sizzle reels of like hey
here's what you may have missed that's
on the epic game store come check this
out hey we have a giant sale going on
right now yeah up to 75
check this out free game
check this out
it was a big it was a big reminder oh
man i got to add to this 100 100 game
list that you know i've maybe played
like open a few of them i did that
yesterday
when uh when they did the commercial for
epic games it was open and they were
like they're like hey man eater is free
right now i was like i thought to myself
i have that on ps5 already because that
was free for playstation plus but
yeah i'll claim it i'll do it without
everything i got an email i gotta i
gotta build my library i gotta look at
all this all this crap i'll never play
exactly i'll turn on for 10 minutes oh
god control
but i will play control 600 times if i
have to
that'll probably be the only game again
i pick game store which i already own on
like three consoles anyway so what i am
trying to do though
was sign up for the closed beta for uh
what's this called disney speed storm
and it ain't working i mean this is an
epic site it's it's disney's uh the
website for the game
maybe too many people are trying to jump
on it as well i don't know you know the
game looks kind of hot so it's great it
was like when that came on i was like oh
yeah this and then devante's like
well
i'm not even that big on kart racers i
mean uh hot wheels unleashed kind of
really like gripped me but um other than
that i'm not huge on kart racers yeah
but that silver screen level
i'll give it i'll give it that yeah it
looks pretty it looks fun i at least
want to try the beta um well you know
what you could just wait for it to go is
it going to be free to play do we know
that is it going to be full release
that's a good question all i know is
that they're going to make it free
gotta go get in my library and then
never touch it ever again
uh yeah who knows but you know there's
one i think we've seen it before but can
we talk about raw men for a second
sure
i i just don't know
what to say about it because a bunch of
raw men what type of game is wrong i
actually don't know i i was trying to
figure out i think it's an arena i think
it's an arena game it's definitely
multiplayer and i heard you say a
meatball that's what you think that ball
they were in
whirling around was is that a ball of
meat with string okay
because yeah i was what do you think it
was i was completely confused i it could
have been like pieces of brain or
something i have no clue i mean there's
a lot of food emphasis on that or a ball
of ramen stuck together tied together
i'm just gonna assume that was a big old
meatball
rolled together by a bunch of raw men
i don't think roll the meatballs i don't
think that game is gonna go anywhere
come on raw man how do you
so that's that's what's going to get you
into the epic game story hey buddy
that's the one that's going to make you
play it
a game on epic game store hey games are
power fantasies am i right and i've
always been like i could be a raw man
let me let me jump let me jump in that
giant human-sized media so something
that caught my way to victory my
attention
and i don't even play this on pc was the
sifu summer update uh i didn't want to
talk about that have you played sifu at
all no okay well um i still haven't
beaten it um even with the lower
difficulty that they added in there but
the modifiers that they're throwing in
there might help me out i'm assuming
this is coming to all versions of the
game because i played on playstation 5
but bullet time
low gravity unbreakable weapons
yes please thank you all right that's
great is it is it going to like
eliminate my my trophies when i play the
game maybe but it's okay that's messed
up that'd be no come on at least i'll be
able to get to the end of the game now
increase punish you for you know for
nancy increased enemy attack speed
right in the
no
we don't eat that
take that back
we don't need that sifu see its way out
yeah okay can't do that
uh other than that breezy breezy thing
you know i didn't i don't think either
one of us walked in expecting a lot you
know they like epic this kind of felt
just like a way to
let people know everyone that's watching
summer game fast who's involved like
this is the thing we have exclusives
they also made a big point to show that
fall guys again because it's going free
to play yep this month on the june 21st
i played that game when it came out and
like there's no reason why i dropped off
of it it just was like
a moment i had a great time yeah
but you know maybe it's like you know
it's in the zeitgeist again oh it will
be my eyes so i'm just eventually it's
gonna it's gonna have you know it's it's
moment in the sun again when people are
playing it on switch and xbox that's
right need to close there as well
whether it
dies out again we'll see did it die out
or did you know i mean maybe just like
it faded a little bit but it was you
know the the height of it was like right
at the height of the pandemic too and
everybody exactly and trying to find
things to play with each other so the
most it did for me
have you ever seen mxc the most extreme
nation yes i played that game and i was
like i think that's why i stopped
playing to be honest i played it for
like a few nights i was like this makes
this give me an itch for uh gram xc and
then you marathoned all of that i
yes
i'm not joking it was early you're right
it was early pandemic i was like having
zoom parties with mxc so nice thank you
fall guys
anyways folks uh we're gonna take a
quick break
real quick i don't know we'll be back in
15 minutes the tribeca game festival
showcase is happening um game spotlight
is happening at 12 o'clock so we'll be
here at 11 45 to have a little pre-show
again um or this you know show up at 11
45 you know we'll kind of ease into it
we don't really know we have a list of
what we're going to see but um we'll be
talking about that uh we'll just be
chilling well just relaxing it's a cool
chill day of the day summer game fest
was yesterday it's a friday you know the
big the big reveal is yeah it's a friday
happy friday folks
uh yesterday was a big day for reveals
jeff keely and the sneakers
kind of have a cool easy just like cool
showcases these next couple days and
then sunday
xbox but that's the showcase yep that's
the one that show up for you show up for
all of it but that's the one you should
definitely be present i'm expecting
nothing
you're expecting god of war
all right folks thank you so much this
is gamespot's coverage of summer game
fest you just watched the epic games
store summer showcase nailed it i'm
current devina that's devonte chisholm
over there we'll see you back in just
about 15 minutes come back 11 45 come
hang out with us all right see you later
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
talking jibber jabber and going over
what we've seen what we've liked what we
haven't liked and what we're hoping to
see in the future so today's tribeca we
just had up a game stores this summer
summer showcase i can't i can't i have
not been able to say it because it's not
really the summer yet you know so you're
getting tripped up because it's the
spring sure yeah that's fine
thanks devonte covered me
yeah that's exactly as we sit in front
of the word summer over here
uh but we gotta look at that just a
moment ago so if you stuck around and
you're back thank you for joining us
again tribeca's cool tribeca is
interesting um they they don't they kind
of came
i'm most i think i remember them coming
for the first time into this mix last
year i could be totally wrong so i
apologize in advance and they had a
really really interesting cool showcase
of games that like you may know but then
a bunch of other stuff that i didn't
even hear about yeah um and this year
i'm kind of expecting the same or at
least at least that's the kind of the
expectation i have it's like you know
it's like
tribeca is all about films the film
festival and also they're like hey games
are cool and you know i'm like
you're right they are
and i mean you know stories
can be just like
films in a way like the game stories i
think one of them that they they might
show i think you had mentioned it before
immortality
isn't that like comic book yes can i
talk about that go for it can i talk
about it i don't know much about it all
right so immortality i mean who knows
like if it you know i'm just excited
about it it's very up
my alley it's a very curt
game so this is uh this is from a
developer who did who's usually who
specializes in doing fmv full motion
video
kind of investigative detective games uh
the first big one was her story oh okay
her story fantastic yeah um and then he
did telling lies right after yeah uh but
this one is interesting because from
what i understand you're going through
you're you're investigating what
happened to this one specific actress
and you're doing it by going through old
film reels of other of many films she's
been in like so we're talking like
you're just going through the raw
footage of these movies and this has you
have the ability while watching while
going through all this footage to like
click on specific items in
uh a certain real film and then it'll
take you to another real film that that
specific item existed in so you like you
kind of the way all of his games work is
like you don't aren't really given
instructions yeah her story started out
like you're just given a database like
you're on a normal computer and you're
just given footage of a woman's
testimonies of a crime you don't exactly
know what the crime is but you just
search keywords and every single time
you search a keyword you find new things
and eventually you start to piece it
together on your own okay and something
i find so brilliant about her stories
like the game doesn't really have an end
like you once like it's up it's
up to you as a player to decide once
you've pieced it together and you're
like okay it's like inception good which
means i'd love it love it i love it her
story is great all right i got to play
so mortality is kind of feels like a
more visual version of her story in the
sense that like you're looking through
these reels of film and you're piecing
the story together by like looking at
props and different actors you click on
actors on it and it goes to different
things so that's the thing i'm really
most excited to see wait all right i'm
sold i didn't know about it yeah there
you go here i am i'm about to play all
of them are they do you know if they're
connected or not no all three no no no
no
he comes from a background in film and
like so he's a very like movie movie
focused
sort of cat as far as i'm aware um but
they're both on uh so i'm just gonna do
a quick plug her story and uh telling
lies are both on game pass okay um but i
would suggest playing them on pc because
of typing this one might be a little bit
better with controller but there is a
game here that i know you're excited to
see yeah tell me about it
so i am excited to see a plague tale
requiem because again game pass
got me into a playtale innocence and
that game was just fantastic you know
despite me being a little scaredy cat i
really enjoyed
i just love rats
discovering you know the that story and
finding ways around the rat puzzles and
stuff i i'll admit when i first started
playing it yeah those rides were weird
it gave especially like if you're at the
menu and the way they like swarm through
the screen on the menu when you're not
even playing it's like it did give me
that oh that like itchy feeling that
even like bugs give me something but by
the end of that game or even by the
middle of it i was just kind of like
caring about the characters in a way i
didn't expect to
like hugo is like such an annoying like
little brother character that you kind
of don't really like too much in the
beginning i feel like but i was a little
brother yeah by the end
i i felt more like amicia and i was just
like no i gotta i gotta protect you
like you are
you gotta grow old with me we we are we
are blood hugo let's do this thing you
know so
fantastic and i
getting getting a sequel
to it was a huge surprise to me when
that was announced so
it's been like it's been highly
anticipated for me ever since the cool
thing that's uh
you also just have a thing for like we
talked about this yesterday in the
stream because he's a big last of us fan
you just like people looking after each
other yeah just like people looking
after little ones it's weird yeah it's
not weird it's it's just inside of your
heart it's interesting you know because
yeah like i don't i never really notice
it until like someone points it out and
then i'm able to be like oh yeah all
right bioshock witcher uh
even batman with robin like all of them
like my favorite characters and just
like
these these characters that are taking
other characters under their wing and
protecting them and stuff so okay i'll
be under your wing
or i don't know
my son
my son kurt hi it's me yeah
uh the one thing that's kind of
interesting or really cool that tribeca
is doing this time around uh is they're
having the ability for people to play or
try these games out at home so
traditionally the future is here
traditionally with these kind of
festivals and these things e3 and
showcases and all that jazz you'd have
to be in person
well welcome to 2022 we've been we've
been virtual for far too long even
though i'm sitting in a real room with
devonta in which i can actually
high five gotta do it i cannot do bam
uh
but in any case if you're staying at
home you don't have that opportunity you
don't have that privilege to go to a
showcase and be able to play these games
hands on they have a hold thing i don't
know full details yet so i'm not gonna
spew too much about it well i'm sure
we're gonna learn about it during the
showcase yeah uh where you can
stream these games at your home you pay
five bucks for a pass and i think that
gives you access 30 minute access to a
small you know like i think they might
be showing eight or ten games off so
like i think a plague tale raccoon was
one of them i think mortality is one of
them yep there's a game that i'm seeing
here right now called as dusk falls
look
it's a title that's like
definitely something i would want to
know you yeah it's your soul it's also
an xbox i mean xbox is publishing it
cool um so that's interesting we might
see that sunday as well
sunday but you can you can if you're at
home right now you can pay five dollars
you can stream some of these games and
actually try them out for yourself i
would like to try out immortality a
great deal although at the same time i
might just wait
yeah because i want to like because it's
like i don't want to deal with the tease
i don't want to deal with like booting
it up
and like getting i'm a very big
detective person i'm a very big uh
investigative kind of person and i don't
i do not want to get 30 minutes into
unraveling this person's mystery and
then have it shut off and be like no i
ain't and lead it that whole time until
release you're just like thinking about
the clues you've done i'll just what's
happening i'll i'll wait i'll be patient
i'll
unravel the mystery of this old times
the actress i also have a thing for old
films i'm just i'm just
we'll see we'll see of course i have to
hold you know
my expectations have to be in check yeah
we have to wait for that see now me i
don't know because this is going from
the 11th to the 19th so got a few days
i'm on the west coast right now but when
i return to the east coast
i don't know you might you might see me
take a trip over to soho and uh
experience
requiem in real life you know oh is it
take a selfie with me an uh immersion or
immate
immortality don't do that be like look
at what i'm playing right now just
don't do it no no i won't even i won't
even respond to that there's a lot of
coolest looking stuff though on the
website we have um
like we have a game called thirsty
studios or i'm sorry thirsty super
shooters my dyslexic came out for a
second thirsty suitors um that i saw a
little bit about i think last week i was
really curious about there's also
oxenfree too
there's a lot of oxenfree fans out there
yeah a lot of kids love that stuff not
kids but you know you people you know
who you are you know who love it so it's
like that's a highly anticipated game
that's coming um all of it's where i
think we're gonna get a good look at it
today
um
so yeah i love it i'm or at least i'm
just excited i think tribeca is a really
really
different i don't know it's like it's
like we have we have our devolver we
have you know we have our look at like
the big ones the big guns we have dave
the devs and i think tribeca is like
feeling a really specific kind of gap of
like these games that are like
they're curated in a way like tribeca
seems to have a really good hand on like
like on on curating like a small
selection that's
you know really good to what it is that
tribeca stands for which is a certain
appreciation of medium of interactive or
at least visual medium yeah in this case
they're going on to games
the interactive medium
of games
um
other than what else you see
you got anything else
no that's that's really it as far as
what they have on the website oh wait i
clicked
i clicked back and totally forgot about
american arcadia we saw that yesterday
oh yeah achilles thing yeah let's talk
about that for a second that looks
pretty cool
so
again if i can even if i could play that
earlier honestly that was a game that
that was a game that after the summer
game fest i like i had on a list and we
were just slamming through things
there's just so much that was showing
and american arcadia put up by raw fury
um yeah
it's like uh i didn't entirely it looks
almost like a
like a truman show style experience
where you play as this person in a
metropolis this utopian city that's
being filmed and broadcast at all times
as a tv show and i'm assuming like has
an image and he's trying to be so
perfect and stuff like that but until
one person's like i gotta get out i'm
out of here i'm out and i think it looks
cool like i think it's a really cool
concept
um and i feel like that was like that i
saw it for the first time yesterday
yeah i had seen some rumblings on
twitter about it um just like i guess
like images and things like that but to
finally like see it in action and get
that trailer and kind of get like a
taste of the story
definitely
had me had me interested he also
reminded me of another game that i'm
blanking on the name of or like was it
we happy few or something like that yeah
yeah i mean we have a few as like a it
was like an immersive sim where it's
like
this is there's nothing to do with it
but you know it's like an immersive
symbol it's like you have to this this
perfect world where these people to take
happy pills yeah but once you're off the
pills you actually see that the world is
like
in complete shambles yeah um i just want
to take the second though at least a
moment right now to just remind everyone
that we're doing this
for the entirety of summer game fest
we're even going on monday uh because
there's gonna be capcom showcase where
we're gonna get a look
at resident evil 4.
not remake just resume 4. i have to keep
the use of that they're just they're not
calling it a remake they're calling i
don't know we'll talk about that on
monday
um so stay around like stay tuned keep
it here at gamespot uh we have coverage
of everything happening we also have
interviews going up
on our youtube channel happening with uh
lucy james it's more hussein who are in
la right now uh on the show floor so i
mean there there isn't really a show
floor but they're in a room in which
they're bringing people in they have
we're gonna have a bunch of exclusive
interviews and looks at the games that
are coming that are gonna be shown this
weekend so please stick around stay with
us while we do this um
but yeah we have tribeca coming up we
went through epic games just before
what's your wild prediction let's watch
just something random you want to see
today
from tribeca um i want to see
what do you want to see more of i just
my wild thing that i want to see is like
a new game
where it's like somehow
vr but not vr at the same time and it's
like it's a game but it's also a movie
and it's starring you and you can kind
of project yourself into the game this
is going i feel like it's we're going
down like a hideo kojima type route
right here um but that's
that's what i want to say i want i want
a way to
find something throw myself into a game
yeah i want to be you not you vr and vr
i want to play a game but i want to live
a life that i live
live my life love love love love your
life live laugh love
so make it make it for quest yeah
show it to me make it for reality make
it for the make it for the world who
knows tribeca is interesting we'll see
what we get
i think we're going to just take a break
it's about to start and any time now 10
seconds uh thanks again folks you're
here with gamespot doing the coverage of
summer game fest this is davonte
chisholm i'm current avina stick around
after tribeca because we're going to be
coming back
talk about what we saw yep see you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all for joining us for the
second annual tribeca games spotlight a
several of tribeca selections this year
are second acts as well sequels that
return to worlds or characters that we
love and fresh perspectives and new
adventures some tell stories about
family cultural identity and coming of
age as a child a teen or an adult facing
a world that never stops changing they
invite us to investigate mysteries and
navigate familiar
yet dangerous terrain or simply just
cook a meal with people we love others
explore our fears about the future
through dystopian tales of environmental
ruin or technology run amok
but all of them offer us an opportunity
to think
play and challenge ourselves
whether that means a much needed break
from the worries of our daily lives or
an experience that tells us something
true
about what it means to be alive
whatever you're looking for chances are
you're gonna find a little bit of it in
these games here are the 2022 tribeca
game selection
[Music]
it isn't always easy going back to the
place where you grew up for jala the
star of thirsty suitors going back home
for her sister's wedding means that
she's going to be facing unresolved
issues with her family her friends and a
string of angry exes
as jala you're going to be forced to
confront everything that you have been
avoiding through cooking challenges and
colorful turn-based battles where you're
going to be face-to-face with the
biggest adversary of all
the decisions you made in the past
hope your bag is packed it's time for a
trip back home with thirsty suitors
outer lip games is a fully remote studio
that we started five years ago with the
idea of making games about
underrepresented cultures and themes the
studio is about 15 folks and we're
scattered from seattle washington to
vancouver to the uk toronto east coast
of u.s like new york and then two in
brisbane our first project was game
called falcon age it's an active
adventure game about raising a falcon
and fighting colonizers falcon age was
the first time
i personally have ever worked closely
with someone else who's brown and south
asian on a team i've been in the
industry for about eight years by that
point so
that's actually pretty shocking when you
think about it and i think one of the
great things about that for me was the
kind of conversations you can have the
kind of work that you can do and you're
coming from a similar basis and a
similar background and experience that's
why i was really excited about working
on thirsty suitors
hey y'all
you've been reckless with other people's
hearts for so long jala it was a matter
of time before you wrecked your own
morning ma
thirsty sitters is an action-adventure
rpg about immigrant culture resolving
relationships family pressure and
finding oneself
timber hills
our hometown
i still don't get why we're back here
jala is an extremely relatable character
for anyone who's really had that moment
of moving away from home and then coming
back
she
sometimes isn't quite aware of the
things that she's doing in terms of like
hurting people
maybe i should just call tyler and get
it over with
i mean yes tyler's your ex bestie but
she's also your ex
the ex
she's kind of a hot mess at the
beginning of the game and that sets up
an interesting dynamic for the player to
get to know each of her exes
because your third grade boyfriend just
walked in the door
every time you battle one of your exes
they go into their own inner space like
a fantasy land you look surprised to see
me jala
or are you just admiring the view
so the way we design combat is based on
like a non-violent beating up with each
other what i consciously did was not to
have any punches that connect all the
props are being used as thrown objects
or
punches and kicks exist but they only
exist in the form of like a holographic
fist that comes out
[Music]
come on sergio
let's dance
did i mention i spent a year abroad i
learned a lot of new moves
trying to distract me with your chest
hair is definitely cheating when we
started thinking about the visible
inspiration it was about coming up with
a style that matched the
lightheartedness
and the theme of the game that i wanted
to
create
artwork that felt light that felt bold
graphic
with vivid colors
i love you tala i have loved you since
our hands met reaching for the same tub
of lime green play-doh in third grade
love me this is the longest conversation
we've had in over a decade
i enjoyed the fact that this game is
about reconciliation because that's
something that a lot of people don't get
to do in real life
i'm sorry i came on so strong
i've had this fantasy of you in my head
for so long
it's time i got to know the real you i'm
ready to move on if you are i'm glad we
figured that out in a lot of families
food plays a large role in the culture
and a large role in learning things from
your parents and being able to pass
those on and it's a part of jala's
journey being able to reconcile that
relationship with her parents it's an
outlet for her to be able to do that on
their grounds and you know reconnect
with her culture
the skating session in our game is
supposed to be really easy and
accessible
i didn't want to make like this hardcore
skate simulator so the way i've designed
the game is to make the players be able
to do fun looking things like wall run
grinds and other acrobatic tricks on a
skateboard without the complexity of
button inputs
from where we're coming from we're
making this game we want it to feel very
familiar to immigrants and
people of color and particularly like
south asians so that they can
see themselves but i think it's also a
very
enjoyable act of like speculation and
fantasy for
anyone else you know come be part of
this we're making a role-playing game
part of the pleasure of that is in
inhabiting someone else and living their
life and i think that's kind of what we
want to give players this idea of being
very grounded in jala this very specific
character and her story and her
personality some of which are shaped by
her culture and some of which is who she
is
[Music]
imagine a world where the richest people
on the planet move to mars in the midst
of a climate catastrophe in the cub
that's the question facing a child who
has found a way to survive in the ruins
of a mutated earth
but when the ultra rich return on an
expedition
they may get a lot more than what they
bargained for
[Music]
demagogue studio is a group of
filmmakers writers architects musicians
animators and developers who make
interactive experiences for a generation
that might just live to witness the end
times
we started experimenting with a couple
of satirical games that led to golf club
wasteland
our first commercial success
currently we demagogues are working on
two games
one of which is a prequel and sequel to
golf club wasteland
a 2d cinematic platformer called the cub
[Music]
the cub is essentially the jungle book
set in an urban silicon valley-like
apocalypse
[Music]
after the great climate catastrophe
the ultra rich have evacuated to tesla
city on mars
the rest of us died
years later
when a research mission revisits earth
they spot a human-like mutant kid while
playing golf
upon discovering the cub the science
expedition turns into a relentless
safari like hunt
the kid ducks and dives through urban
ruins the little barbarian bastard has a
plan
[Music]
while traversing this vibrant
post-apocalyptic world the cub wears a
space helmet he scavenged from a dead
martian
the helmet airs radio nostalgia from
mars a radio station based on mars
streaming music and stories of tesla
city dwellers memories of their former
home
earth
the radio callers are nostalgic for our
today
this is future archaeology
future retro
a sci-fi scenario that prompts us to
reevaluate the things we already have
today
from friends and family to basic things
like air and water
as marshall mcluhan would say we march
backwards into the future
similarly the brutalist architecture in
the environment serves many non-obvious
functions
brutalism stands for the 20th century
and its apocalyptic war history
it stands for faith in large-scale
progress through technology that spans
multiple ideologies which led to
breakthroughs but also to pollution and
climate change
in the 21st century we have a brutalism
of the soul a re-ordering of the human
psyche through the internet as
exemplified in the millennial pink neons
peppered throughout our game cityscapes
such as digidopamine
or doomscrolling
modernist architecture looks powerful
yet it's already turning into ruins
just as humanity might
the game is an homage to cinematic
platformers such as heart of darkness
but also old-school sega games like the
jungle book or aladdin
[Music]
[Music]
further inspiration is drawn from
classic literature cinema and popular
culture
a reflection on our commitment to
storytelling and world building
the game has numerous interactive
objects to find that enrich and inform
the narrative and also poke fun at
future and current events at the same
time
[Music]
hopefully the game will make people feel
open the players minds and thereby bring
a change in global politics and a
universal bliss for all humanity
you know what platformers are best at
enlightenment of the soul
[Music]
in 1998 the fates of two families
converge at a motel in the arizona
desert where a robbery gone wrong
changes all of their lives forever
as the tale unfolds over the next few
decades step into the shoes of multiple
characters to decide how that night will
alter the course of their lives through
a unique art style featuring actors
digitally integrated into a beautiful
cinematic world
this is as dusk falls
hello i'm caroline and i'm cherry we're
excited to be here and we'd love to tell
you more about interior night and our
game as dusk falls
oh hey there got your car towed back for
you you were right it's more than i can
fix with duct tape and a socket wrench
what do i owe you nothing
your guests
[Music]
as those fools is an interactive story
the decisions you make do have
consequences
[Music]
our story is a crime drama that explores
the intertwined lives of two families
over 30 years
we have the loving family the walkers so
what's next license plate game another
round of row row row
and the halls
which are the more desperate family
come on this is two rock not nypd blue
now get looking for that safe as you
play the game you will be stepping in
the shoes of different characters
first vince the dad who is rooting his
family to missouri you are my flock and
i plan to herd you to st louis in high
spirits
and on their way in arizona they get
caught in a hostage situation
[Applause]
there's also jay who is one of the
member of the other family the hostage
takers so you get to see understand the
world from his perspective jay
what head out of the clouds little bro
look
there's enough cash in that safe to put
the last few weeks behind us we stay
alive we keep the house everything goes
back to normal
there is our third main character who is
zoe
daddy are we gonna play you bet we're
gonna play who you see across the six
chapters from when she's six until she's
19 and she's becoming this young woman
[Music]
the visual art style of our game is
unique and it was crafted especially to
tell this compelling story it mixes
beautifully painted 2d characters and
sets them in an evocative 3d world
we film genuine and nuanced performances
from actors to capture complex emotions
and facial expressions players don't
look at pixels they watch people in all
their humanity
[Music]
when it comes about like writing the
story
we work probably a bit more like tv
it's a very long process dozens of
versions of script so it's not a linear
one version of the story we have to
think
all the choices all the narrative space
all the branches feeding into one
another it's kind of a 3d map
[Music]
how could you have thought you'd be
happier without your family
i mean without mine i'd i'd be i don't
know
i guess i just never liked being tied
down
with a family i
felt
trapped
we rule every character from a place of
empathy and we try not to be judgmental
towards any of them we try to understand
each of them and i hope the players will
feel the same way and try to empathize
and understand and relate with all of
them did you get the money oh we got it
all right
nice work guys hold on tight
[Music]
family meals are a time not just to
create memories but to share them for
wenber the mother of the family cooking
is a way to connect to the culture and
the life that she has left behind and
pass those memories on to a young son
each recipe she teaches him is not just
a list of ingredients but a piece of a
much larger story about where he comes
from who his family is and the
challenges they face here's a taste of
what's to come in november
how did you get started in game
development
well basically i took a quiz online to
figure out what my career should be back
when i was in high school and after i
did the quiz it said i should be a video
game developer
we were working on this project called
balloon man it was this mega man style
boss rush game about this depressed
superhero whose superpowers are only to
make balloons we were a couple of months
into the project when abby texted me
this uh paragraph pitch of venva i was i
remember the day i was eating at a
restaurant with my mom and my sister
benbe is a narrative cooking game where
you play as a manpad who moves to canada
in the late 1980s but during this move
her wrist people gets damaged so as the
player not only will he be cooking
various south indian dishes to restore
these recipes but he will also be
exploring uh the story of this family
and the unique challenges that they face
and the idea
resonated with me so much
maybe because my mom was there i felt um
a connection to the idea because it's
about a mother and a son it was too
compelling to
uh not work on
so we decided to move on to venma when
the at its core is about the
relationship between the mother and the
son one aspect that we wanted to touch
upon was the loss of language as kevin
grows up here and grows more assimilated
he loses touch with his mother and he
adopts
english instead so as a result the
literal communication between wenba and
kevin is quite broken and you can see
this in the recipe book given to benbow
by her mother as well because in the
travel the words and the pages get
damaged so as a result the communication
between generations there too is quite
broken
binba who feels a lot of guilt for
having moved to canada in the first
place doubles down on the things she
holds a theater like her culture her
language or food the longer she stays
here so it becomes really important for
her to fix the recipe book
because for her that's a way for this
link to persist across generations
in our household we very rarely ate
outside food so cooking was very
important everything was made from
scratch and daily
and unlike bamba there were no recipes
food was just made by testing taste
improvising and asking around
the cooking game place specifically was
a big challenge for us
[Music]
most cooking games that we know take a
lot of the physical elements of cooking
like chopping an onion or flipping a pan
and turn those into actual gameplay
mechanics this didn't really fit the
theme in the story of venba and that's
where the damage recipe book idea came
to fruition
we thought that a puzzle-based cooking
game made for a much more compelling and
appropriate gameplay mechanic
[Music]
[Music]
i wanted the sound effects to be really
realistic and reminiscent of the south
asian kitchen i recorded like the dish
word that we use some utensils just
items from the kitchen
but that also involves a lot of
recording of actual cooking
i wanted the sounds to be very nostalgic
for those that grew up in a similar
background
i wanted this emotional impact to come
across through sound
the music in this game it primarily
comes from an in-game radio influenced
by summer movies and music that were a
huge part
of my life growing up and we took a lot
of effort to make sure that the songs
sound like something you would hear back
home when you would turn the radio on
[Music]
it was the hardest thing for me to
choose what recipes get showcased in the
game it's impossible to do justice to
the wide range of dishes and
cuisines that we have instead i just
focused on what recipes would make for
fun gameplay puzzles and what
ingredients would this family have
living in toronto even though the story
of emba is pretty firmly rooted in tamil
culture we think it hits on some pretty
universal themes
[Music]
the influences for this game it
primarily draws from the stories of the
families that i see here especially the
relationship between first generation
parents and their children
we're hoping that in the future we'll
keep being able to tell these kinds of
intimate stories through game gameplay
you know maybe you'll it'll make you
want to call your mother in the end
two years ago the game of plague tale
innocence invited audiences into the
world of omesia a teenage girl living in
14th century france
as amissia you had to use courage in
cunning to protect your five-year-old
brother hugo from soldiers of the french
inquisition swarms of rats carrying the
black plague and the supernatural evil
coursing through hugo's veins
now armisia and hugo are back in a new
adventure called a plague tale requiem
get ready for hand-to-hand battles on
ruin castles thrilling adventures on the
high seas
and yes
more rats than ever
[Music]
she doesn't deserve
[Music]
[Music]
is it
the bite yes
they knocked the arena down they let
them die here
it's starting all over again
several
foreign
i don't know what's happening to me
lucas
i i feel my mind going
in concern
um
foreign
it's bleeding again
yes we should fix that before it gets
infected i guess
it's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you should sit down
oh so that's all you have to say
come on
you can do better than that you have a
whole garrison here why don't you really
let yourself go stop
no
do you see the situation we're in
we were just supposed to get herbs
technology
yeah
[Music]
flexibility or in terms of tornadoes
i don't know what's happening to me
lucas
i i feel my mind going
unclear is
is
[Music]
[Music]
would his majesty allow us to enter the
city by his side
i allow
[Music]
when cuphead came out in 2017 the first
thing people noticed was
the distinctive cartoon art style
inspired by the golden age of american
animation where every frame was drawn by
hand now cuphead is back with a new
adventure called delicious last chorus
with a whole bunch of new enemies and
ways to die and a new heroine named ms
chalice so
if you are up for the challenge get
ready for cuphead delicious last course
[Music]
after the first game released
we had that itch to go back and revive
some of them
[Music]
we had always envisioned her playing a
really important role as part of the
main trio of heroes
this was our opportunity to further
explore animation music
gameplay homages all of which we didn't
get to in the first game
[Music]
[Music]
the origin of the original cuphead
character
we probably went through about 300
concepts we began brainstorming in the
1930s tradition of giving inanimate
objects faces and personalities
we really wanted to create essential
character that could sit alongside some
of the iconic joyful heroes we loved
growing up like felix the cat and mickey
and bimbo
and then one day we just had one of
those
amazing aha moments when a loose sketch
of a silhouette of a cup and a straw
began to take form that would eventually
become
cuphead
[Music]
having the chance to re-explore this
world to make something special for our
fans
while taking our time
on the little details and making sure
we're getting them just right in so many
ways cuphead
game and character has been with our
whole team through life's many changes
these characters have become like
children of sorts
and getting a chance to take them on a
new adventure to close this chapter of
their story is just really exciting
well there's a new challenge waiting
around every corner on the amazing dlc
island
[Music]
[Applause]
2016's oxenfree introduced the
supernatural coming of age story of a
teenage girl named alex and her friends
celebrating the end of a school year on
the mysterious edwards island
contemplating their futures
and accidentally opening a ghostly rift
oxen 3-2 lost signals brings us a
different kind of coming-of-age story
one about riley in her 30s facing the
choices she made as a young adult and
figuring out what comes next
this is oxen free 2 lost signals
welcome welcome first we're going to
have a little fun tonight
in their radio folks
ah bit of a leap there oh we could climb
down here also it might take a little
longer
i just don't think we can make the gap i
can make it probably
can you
because
well uh we'll see won't we
[Music]
riley
riley
what i think has allowed oxenfree to
have such a long life in the hearts of
our players are these characters it's
all about the characters the characters
of oxenfree are intended to feel like
people that you would know you're
invested in their well-being the issues
that they deal with are ones that
everybody can relate to what does it
mean to lose somebody that you love what
does it mean to be entering a new moment
of your life that you're totally
unprepared for it's open-ended enough
that you can always ask yourself what
would i do in this situation
watch yourself i don't think this was
meant for tourists
it's
sort of pretty
in a way
no
it's amazing in another life it would
have been a geologist
or took at least an intro to geology
course you know
oxenfree is is a game about some really
relatable characters but put in crazy
unrelatable situations riley's from
kamina and unlike alex and her friends
in oxenfree one riley did not have the
best time growing up in this area the
first game really tight kind of focus on
a few classmates this game is about
riley coming home and interacting with
jacob who is somebody who she went to
high school with dealing with her father
dealing with a whole host of new
characters that are along this coast
if you
know the tunnel is well enough you can
walk to and from practically any point
in town completely underground
have you uh been down here before
me uh
personally no
some of the kids do or did in high
school they crawl in here light a fire
make out or whatever
but i'm too little a fan of small dark
spaces to really see the desire i'm
really looking forward to people playing
with jacob who is their kind of main
counterpart throughout the game take a
look at jacob he's got this
questionable facial hair he's got the
hipster hat funny huh just a little
light makes everything both less and
more spooky weird right
and his animation also gave him that
laid back kind of hey i'm just hanging
out here in the woods not being creepy
jacob actually has direct ties to the
events of oxy 1 and particularly the
history of maggie adler maggie was the
woman that first kind of discovered
what radios could do she was the one who
was kind of tied to the events that
really kicked off the whole story
if you're on this frequency
yes
my mom used to tell me stories that's
why i'm calling because one of the
stories was about tonight and the things
that are going on the cool thing about
the radio is that it opens up
a whole different axis of exploration to
the player it's not just exploring
edwards island as a space it's exploring
edwards island as an infinite number of
kind of radio frequencies certain
objects in the game will will resonate
with certain frequencies
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it worked i think i mean
we're not dead the alternate timelines
in the oxford universe are really
interesting because it allows the player
to explore the possibility of going back
and changing the past i think we're back
when the mine was somewhat operational i
don't think anyone's around
let's uh see if the time tear opened
anything up the player gets to open
these portals in time and go through
them and talk to these other ghostly
characters portals are getting open when
they don't want it to happen and so
they've got to deal with the
ramifications of that portals are
fascinating very beautiful very
mysterious
but ultimately very dangerous
jacob
the stakes are very high for this one
one we've got a new set of antagonists
who are uh actually actively trying to
open a portal on their own for some
nefarious reasons but two while that is
happening we're seeing tears in time
those tears are allowing things from
completely other timelines to start
coming in and out of our timeline it's
going to be much less about some
localized little thing in this town and
it's more about the fabric of time and
space kind of melting down
i mean look when you're messing with the
time space continuum that's just a bad
idea
riley come in riley
can you hear me
riley are you there
[Music]
in immortality created by sam barlow
full transparency i'm a huge fan of his
previous games her story and telling
lies you don't just find one you find
three unreleased films spanning over
three decades and they all star
marissa marcel who has since
disappeared so can you
watch footage and behind the scenes
clips and interviews to piece together
the mystery of marissa marcel
this
is immortality
what is your name marissa marcel first
heard about marissa marcel in 2015. i
was at a party in hollywood and i was
listening to these old guys
writers producers who were big in the
70s they were swapping war stories
gossiping and one of them brings up the
story of marissa
this actress who shoots three movies
over three decades
and how none of the movies ever comes
out
i was interested and after the party i
went home and i googled and found very
little of anything online
but i was intrigued so i continued to
dig and attempted to find something more
concrete
now we know you from the movie that you
just finished
it is finished right yeah it's finished
yeah if you don't know it's a bit of a
fairy tale so arthur fisher the great
director who uh you probably know from
his movie such as marion and the man who
dreamed was casting for his new movie
ambrosio and so instead of casting a
recognizable face he uh he wanted to
find some fresh talent so he put the
word out and saw how many was it uh ten
thousand i think it was over twenty
thousand twenty thousand he saw twenty
thousand girls and long story shorts he
picked you yes two years ago we were
approached by an anonymous donor who
handed over this huge cache of film
and it was footage from rehearsals
behind the scenes b-roll and completed
shots from the shoots as far as we can
tell
this is everything that remains of the
three mrsa marcel movies
before i go i would like some token of
our friendship
[Music]
you could have walked away from this
we brainstormed how best to use this
footage how to make it available to the
world um so first we very carefully
cleaned and scanned all of the film
digitizing everything
but there were enough gaps where we
weren't able to cut full movies
so we took some of the ideas from my
earlier games her story of talent
the idea of a more exploratory way of
viewing film stories and we built on
that
we created a virtual movie over a way of
looking through the footage as if you
were back in the editing screen arthur
fisher or john dirk
and to build on this idea we came up
with a new mechanic a kind of visual
concordance
does this work as confession
exploration by match
good work
[Music]
when you're watching at any point you
can stop and point to an image an actor
a prop and the system will create a
match cut to another piece of protect
with that image now it's worth more
so you kind of surf through the footage
in a way following a breadcrumb trail of
visuals creating your own montage
[Music]
it's both expressive and exploratory
like the best of video
[Music]
games when you have a situation like
this where no one really knows what
happened to marissa marcel
people tend to fill in their blanks
their imagination goes to dark places
i would not use the word haunted
[Music]
do you ever wish you lived in a simpler
safer more optimistic time
trevor hill does
he lives in arcadia a utopian-american
town in the 1970s where the future seems
brighter than ever like the other
citizens of arcadia he is a contestant
on a reality show where viewers are
secretly judging his every move
when trevor learns the truth from a
rogue technician he goes on the run but
how do you escape in a world where
everyone is always watching
in america
now in its 55th season
american arcadia
[Music]
control subject on the run on camera
4025 interrupt broadcast immediately
stop immediately
in
the hallway to the server room is
tracked by three surveillance cameras i
need to get close to the cameras and
upload the loop footage from my cell
phone
is
yes trust me
all the videos are uploaded and playing
the loops i can enter the server room
now
[Music]
[Music]
tenta
[Music]
hey uh
hey i i can't see anything in here jeez
man just hug your teddy bear real tight
while i try to turn on the lights okay
okay is that better now let's try to
find a way out of here
trevor are you wheezing you're in
terrible shape man
don't you get any exercise at all
no not not since pe in high school
because of my metabolism i
don't easily gain weight so i don't
usually okay i'm not here to judge your
lifestyle or your dietary habits just
save your breath and keep going
in american arcadia what we want to tell
is that you don't need to live just for
getting likes on social networks just do
the things that make you happy you don't
need to care about what the others think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to gamespot's coverage of
summer game fest 2022. we just got done
watching the tribeca game spotlight i'm
here with davonte chisholm
welcome back world premiere devonte's
face
and i'm your host
curtin davina it is such a pleasure to
be here with all of you all you viewers
now we just got done watching troy back
on let me just tell you i was saying i
was trying to find the words for this
before we got started with tribeca
because i think what tribeca does is
really interesting and i was like try i
was struggling to be like
i want to say they like
present games in a
unique or distinct way it feels like a
curated list and i was kind of like
watching this
uh
we were having a conversation it feels
like tribeca does a really good job of
presenting a very small carry list in a
way that that gives these games prestige
while equally giving a lot of attention
behind the developers who made them yeah
i feel like we equally saw just as much
of the games as we did the people behind
them and
their intent and why they do that
um so i just want to be like i just want
to make that note it'd be like
i dig it what'd you think of it
i thought it was great um
i thought you know we we got a look at
the games like requiem for example um
since that was my hope my all zavon has
been talking about my most hyped one out
of this and just got a little more into
you know things behind the characters
and you know their motivations and
what they went through going from
innocence to
requiem and how the characters are kind
of growing between the two and i think
that's something we wouldn't have got
from like a different type of showcase
um it would have just kind of been like
here's
a big chunk of like gameplay a trailer
or something like that but we're not
gonna go too deep into
just like the little nuances of the
character and behind the scenes so i
like seeing that a lot and even with
your uh
movie movie mortality mortality there
you go that was awesome too and again
you described it to me but seeing it and
have them like really go through it like
that wow is that one thing that sam
barlow who's the producer who mentioned
that they had like enough footage for
some of those that they could have
caught an entire film with it and it's
just like
are we gonna be able to watch those in
their entirety even if i mean like you
know honestly it's like the thing with
fmvs are charming for a lot of different
reasons for me it's like
i just love i don't know i think it
comes from my passion and like this this
long love of film that i've always had
so like seeing implemented in games in a
cool interactive way is like as cheesy
as it can be sometimes i just i just
know i don't know i'm a sucker for it
but like the thing that i think
immortality is doing really well and
like this is kind of going to be a make
or break for something of this nature
is capturing
the decade in which these films are
supposed to be taking place so like we
saw one that was in the 70s we saw like
footage from like a talk show and then
we saw a movie from 1999. that was in
there they had like a very very 1999
like blue filter
water ripples like being reflected off
and i was like little things like that
where it's like
that's how you're gonna sell that
concept like that's how you're gonna
like create this sense of that you're
watching these real movies yeah
and that yeah it's just so impressive
you can click anywhere and it'll find a
match and just
i'm down
i'm down for it now i'm down
i'm down and remember like that's that's
the whole thing about this the about the
tribeca one is that like we can go play
those like you can go play them we can
right now first five dollars five
dollars get a get a pass the tribeca
game pass
uh not related to xbox
just gotta clear that up just gonna make
that clear um but another game that i
thought was kind of cool looking but
again this is a very i feel like
everyone's learning a lot about my
interest in games was uh as dusk falls
which is i realized when we were looking
at it was a game that i think was
announced last year which is very much a
kind of
choose your own adventure uh sort of
game with like these where used real
actors real models that they you know
like
and like illustrate it over and put them
into these scenarios i always find that
animation style like rotoscope yeah
it's so like interesting and unique to
look at i love it yeah that's fantastic
um and again it's like we also got to
look you know it's like unlike other
showcases where we just get like trailer
trailer trailer trailer trailer i just
really appreciate tribeca for actually
being like here's the game and instead
of just showing your trailer like here's
the person who made it yeah like we're
gonna be able to get a little bit about
it like they slow it down yeah yeah they
opened it up with thirsty suitors
which uh
was that um like you fought people
using non-violence yeah which also was
very interested right i had a really big
cultural scope to it yeah like i was
like for me i think it was like an
indian family and like like this like
this mother came towering over one of
the characters at one point it was like
almost like a like a like this like
attack of some kind of non you know
non-violent attack as they're trying to
go for it yeah the story looks like it's
going to be really interesting the
characters the way they interact and
talk to each other the way you pick
dialogue to kind of go back and forth
and fight each other it really has this
way of like right away you want to kind
of compare it to scott pilgrim because
of course like battling his exes and in
that
graphic novel comic
movie and game you know side stroller
beat em ups as well everything i'm
surprised there's no netflix like
animated show yet
hire me for the voice acting if you want
to do that who would you be
uh i have no idea i kind of want to just
be nice like a new new character yeah
okay just bring me in as some new
character just devin
just a cool skateboarding kid that
slides in and
you know cool well we just
the netflix
their whole geek week is happening we've
been streaming it
uh they've if you've been watching
netflix
don't take them away from us
that's what i'm gonna say
but yeah um back to what i was saying
though you wanna make the comparison to
scott pilgrim but i think that this game
is going to have enough of its like
uniqueness even with the like
skateboarding challenges yeah that's
going to set it apart i think that's the
thing though it's like on paper
conceptually sure somebody could be like
oh it's like you play this girl who's
going to battle her exes or somebody's
ex's or something that nature's like oh
yeah yeah scott pilgrim but like
it's you know it breathes its own
identity comparison is just what we do
even if it's not because i mean
you know what humans do you know at
least i didn't say it compared to breath
of the wild you know what i mean
everything's a breath of wildlife
every game we saw today every single
game that we saw every single one there
was a shot in a playtale requiem where
hugo was running across a field and
immediately i was like pull out the
sheikah slate link where's the glider
uh the last game that we saw which we
mentioned before but we got to see a
little bit more about it was american
arcadia yeah uh and the trailer like it
kind of gave you an idea that was maybe
like a 2d like a 2d side scroller but
the one thing that stuck out to me is
like it gave me really like inside
game inside sort of vibes like this um
2ds like pseudo 3d world kind of moving
through and i mean inside is like you
know kind of a similar concept you play
as this this
kid yeah inside what the trailer i feel
like didn't really show and and then we
got more
of it here it's the first person aspect
of it which i found kind of surprising
you you play as
um the girl who's trying to help you
escape
and that i i thought she was just a
character there you weren't controlling
her let alone for it to be in first
person you're solving puzzles on that
yes so i think that back and forth
between the two and they even mentioned
how the soundtracks blend that 70s
inspired soundtrack mixed with the more
futuristic soundtrack from her side just
kind of flip-flopping back and forth and
mixing together i i think that's going
to be pretty cool and it's just maybe
it's the 70s vibe oh i mean but it's
giving me death loop vibes as well 1970s
sci-fi which had a cool soundtrack to it
as well very funky soundtrack last year
was the year of
loop games left 4 dead games now we're
going to see
the influence of 70s culture in games
coming back along horror spaces
with space [ __ ] this is like when are
they going to mix the two
we'll find out maybe that's 20 20
routine routine was i think it's like a
futuristic 80s one so it's like oh
there's um we gotta rewind one decade
and that what's the there's there is a
left 4 dead 70s sci-fi shooter oh there
is there were blinking on
cruises
yes yes you got got devonte and a
crucius exists that was like
it is a left for that yeah
okay 1970s i played it sci-fi i played
it for five minutes and and shut it off
so it needs some work very forgettable
sorry
sorry
anyways that's besides the point um
yeah great show like i just it's one of
those things where like um
when you're when you're experiencing
something like this like tribeca you
don't really know you're gonna get
you're not gonna get those big hurrah
like
super surgeons moments i'm like oh my
god they announced this game they
announced the new kojima game like
instead you get like a glimmer into
something that you know you didn't know
you wanted something or like at least a
deeper look into something that you
you're interested in we got this yoxin
free 2 which is a game that people are
excited about we get to learn more from
the dubs i got to see more about
immortality like you know i saw the
trailer but i didn't get to really see
like how much work they put into
actually like
making those those eras of film feel
authentic and
pure so um
i'm a big fan i'm just happy i just i
just you know this is the summer games
festival this is the time which we get
to celebrate be excited about stuff and
look forward to things come in the
future yeah so that said
that's all we got for the day davonte
how you feeling i'm feeling good today
was a nice chill friday you know nothing
nothing too crazy
i feel like we're we're just we're we're
cool and we're on like the lazy river
you know just letting our lunch digest
yeah with a force with a lemonade with a
lemonade yeah before sunday hits and
then it's just like all right we're
getting on the big ride yeah
we're dropping yeah sunday's the sundays
when you know uh you
you take i don't know you do a vacation
what are you doing what would be you're
on the lazy river that's why i say
you're now you're you're lunch we're
going
down the water for the big waters you go
on the lawn
drops you straight nope no log or
anything it's just your body you're
crossing your arms and you're just
going straight down that's what we're
going to get for xbox one sunday at
least we're hoping to get but sunday's
still we still got some time today is
friday tomorrow saturday i'm going to
name every single day of the week
but i just want to let you folks know
gamespot's doing coverage
for all summer game fest defente is
going to be here i'm going to be here
we're going to be joined by lucy james
and tomorrow hussein on sunday to go
over do you have a pre-show post show
for xbox but tomorrow
uh make sure to show up because bright
and early 8am pt we got the gorilla
collective they're going to be showing
some stuff off stuff off and then right
after that we have the wholesome direct
we also have a bunch of exclusive
coverage uh coming in hands-on previews
interviews with all sorts of folk and
things you uh you're going to want to
look cute i don't want to spoil anything
but we're going to have some hands-on
stuff you're going to want to see we're
going to have some interviews with some
devs you're going to want to see and
that stuff's going to be popping up
throughout the weekend so subscribe to
our youtube channel youtube.com forward
slash gamespot and we'll also be showing
off some of that content tomorrow during
the day as well um
and then close out tomorrow we've got
feature game show davonte and i will be
back to
slam it out
get ready for the water slide on sunday
it's been a huge pleasure another great
day happy friday friends yes
i'm current divina that's devonte
chisholm
be cool go play some games stay safe
drink some water play games yeah hydrate
[Music]